ah oui le hasard le destin en
1998 notre dame de paris cette comédie
musicale de luc plamondon et richard
cocciante vous interprétez quasimodo et
c'est ce que vous disiez à l'instant là
tout à coup le déferlement vous êtes
comme satellite et avec toute cette
adoration le public ton véritablement
amoureux de vous et de belles bien sûr
élue chanson du siècle par les français
c'est trop pour un seul homme
c'est trop beau un homme qui voulait
c'était pas du tout le parcours désiré
ou
pouvait pas se rendre compte de ce qui
se passe est très naïve et moi j'y vais
le paradoxe parce qu'ils étaient
imprégnés de quasimodo qui cherchait à
se faire aimer et personne ne voulait de
lui d'être poussant à tous puis allez
inverse quand le show finissait je vais
complètement les verts ce qui inquiète
le dossier de me faire oublier et
donc c'était fait bizarre à vivre
probablement que j'ai chaque post
traumatique
il faudrait faudra aller plus loin dans
la séance et mai mais forcément j'ai
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce qui arrive
et puis en même temps mais je me suis
défoulé dans la fait parce que c'était
là c'était génial c'était peut-être
l'endroit aussi la nuit où j'étais le
plus normal parce que j'allais dans des
endroits où les gens s'en foutent un peu
puis les avaient l'esprit à la fête où
j'avais des conversations beaucoup plus
intense que celle que je pouvais avant
dans la journée quand je marchais dans
la rue comme
des fous
windhoek ça je me suis un peu les fugier
dans la nuit